[موسيقى]
بهاتريك وتتويج بدايه المثاليه لسوالف في
البرازيل رحله المعقده لبرشلونه نحو مدينه
سبته لكي يسخروا من شاكيرا بلوحه سيارته
هذه الاخبار وغيرها نقدمها لكم من العربيه
رياضه اهلا بكم
[موسيقى]
والبرازيلي
الدرجه الاولى
البرازيليهم من دوري الدرجه الثانيه
الموسم الماضي
سيحله برشلونه ضيفا على اتلتيكو سته ضمن
مسابقتي كاس اسبانيا الى الان الخبر عادي
لكن الغريبه في الامر هي كيفيه وصول
الفريق الكاتلوني الى مدينه سبته التي لا
تحتوي على مطار حيث سيكون الفريق مجبرا
على التوجه الى مالاغا علامه طائره قبل ان
يوزع اللاعبون والطاقم على ثلاث طائرات
مروحيه في رحله تمتد لنصف ساعه بينما
ستسافر الاداره من جبل طارق عبر طائره
المروحيه كذلك
لا يزال نجم برشلونه السابق يسخر من
الاغنيه الاخيره لشاكيرا وبعد توفيق عقد
الشراكه
لوحه مميزه على السياره الفرنسيه بتحمل
الرقم
الى اليوم الذي تركت في شاكيرا
الخامس والعشرين منه الماضي
النجمه الايطاليه السابق روبرتو باجو
اثاره جدلا واسعا على السوشيال ميديا بعد
المقابله التي اجراها مع صحيفه الاجازات
اديل سبورت باجو تسال عن المواد التي كانت
تعطي للاعبين في تسعينات القرن الماضي
خاصه بعد وفاه زميلها السابقين
حديثه اذا كانت المكملات الغذائيه وقتها
قانونيه وهسه تخلق مشاكل في اسد اللاعبين
على المدى البعيد
[موسيقى]